so I am going to talk about
responsibilities I have a lot of Mozilla
these days I'm CTO I'm also senior vice
president and engineering and I'm
running around the world with things
like Firefox OS launching but javascript
is still a big responsibility for me
after all these years it's like an 18
year old late bloomer still living at
home over the garage still not cleaning
up after itself so let's let's recap
quickly there's some things to do with
responsibility and I'll stand in line
first for all the blame Crockford tries
to take credit I think he can take
credit for his book but he was years
late I think I met him in 2002 and he
tried to tell me to fix things and at
that point we had no market share at
Netscape we've been crushed by Microsoft
so I said how am I going to fix things
took a while to restart browser
competition and restart standardization
we finally did it who has the power now
it's you might say the standards body
but not really because that's made up of
browser vendors and by the way they
compete for developers I would say the
developers have the power especially
with pretty balanced browser market
structure right now it's really up to
the developers to insist on better
browsers over time which I think people
are working on good faith but I'm still
responsible for JavaScript I'm sort of
the Rainmaker and deal maker and group
hug arranger of the tc39 committee it's
it's kind of a like a family that's been
through a lot of crises somebody
actually said that spontaneously I said
that's so true and there are there more
things to do so let's talk about what to
do one of the things that's happening is
and this is thanks to Raph Weinstein and
other Googlers
who are excited about the rapid release
process of Chrome which Firefox has
adopted of course for several years now
we can't quite do it with standards they
take too long to to check and implement
and look for cross-cutting but
but we can go faster and we think we can
start to paralyse es7 and get maybe an
annual edition of the standardout we'll
see how it goes we're gonna try so I'm
gonna go over s6 quickly you've probably
seen this so don't let me carry with
class syntax but it works for existing
functions including built-in ones like
note list or array you can mix and match
with function constructors there's only
a little bit of extra kernel semantics
it's mostly sugar for functions and
prototypes we have Const and you also
see arrow functions those that bind this
to the outer this there's something that
squares its argument here's another
arrow function this one also shows the
dot dot dot the ellipsis before the T
parameter that means that's a rest
parameter Common Lisp it captures all
the trailing arguments after the first
one which is bound to H and then it
returns an array that's rotated them we
have let better var block structure we
have destructuring I tried to put too
many things together here because I
don't really want to spend more than the
slide on this stuff you boys need it the
structure he's really cool and if I were
really using the Dom it would probably
be something awful like get client
bounding wreck but it never room for it
so there it is and with that object
shorthand you can pluck out the top and
left properties of the returned object a
smart jet could even boil away the
object and just get the top and left
coordinates
here's a default parameter default
argument and this is very handy you can
even refer to prior arguments to assign
later ones you can pass undefined as a
sentinel value to trigger defaulting
which is important when you're
delegating or composing functions you
don't want to have to know all the
combinations of defaults so you can
trigger them by passing undefined
modules are going in in a very
simplified way even from what's been
discussed in the past and it's going to
be very much like I would say like
nodejs
but with the first class syntax so we
can preload things and here's an example
where we're getting the keys and entries
functions from the built in iteration
module you can then use those for things
like the four of luth we couldn't make
four in do this it wasn't backwards
compatible so we have four of kind of
like CoffeeScript
different and there's a key in value
iterator called entries we also have
generators people on the committee
wanted the star in front after the
function to tell you this is a generator
it also allows us to contextually
reserve yield which is not a reserved
word in standards up until es5 strict so
code uses yield a freely for function
names and parameter names so it's very
hard to reserve unconditionally but the
star lets us do it inside the body and
that's the easiest way to implement
iterator by the way there's a lot of
stuff to show here if you guys have seen
this you can go to tank access
compatibility table to see he has a lot
of red but the green is coming in on
spider monkey on v8 some JavaScript core
work lately
Andy Wingo is mentioned by Andrew Hoff
rocky has been doing some great work es6
is happening so i'm gonna talk about new
stuff that's es 7 or if we do this
annual maybe it's es 8 the idea with the
rap edition release for standards is
that we will not necessarily push things
out until they're ready so there's
always a train leaving every year kind
of slow train schedule but it gets
things out when they're ready instead of
trying to hold things up or rush them
through there's something called object
that observed some people are excited
about and it's it's coming along it
needs more work because it ties into
details of the event loop which are
still being hammered out between equity
c 39 and various w3c groups or what WG
folks so I'm going to skip it but I'm
going to talk about low-level JavaScript
because this is important for a couple
of reasons one is the compiler is like
in script and mandrill and really a lot
of other language front ends it's my
contention javascript is evolving to
become a multi language VM and probably
the most successful one because it's the
most widely deployed and it has despite
of having a place of pride for
JavaScript the source language it has a
lot of low-level parts that can serve
other language as well and where it
doesn't we can add them more easily than
you could ever add a new VM in all the
browsers and standardize it so we're
actually using them scripting and this
Asmodeus subset of JavaScript too
show Unreal Engine off and I'll talk
about that
I will Frank's and BOTS but they're also
people hand coding low-level JavaScript
whether they are actually in the azzam
subset or not into doing awesome things
like downloadable video codecs that
compete with the ones in Hardware almost
which is a really cool idea because they
get us away from having to burn things
into hardware that are patented and it
become obsolete sooner than the hardware
dies one of the low-level affordances
that JavaScript really needs is what
we're calling value objects you could
think of these as different numeric
types JavaScript because I was in a rush
and Java had double I'm a double the
number type double precision I Triple E
754 53 bits of mantissa 64 bits total
kind of ugly you know everyone knows
zero point one plus zero point two
equals zero point three zero zero zero
zero zero zero zero zero zero four and
that's blamed on me or blamed on
JavaScript it's actually in all the
languages C Java except those languages
like Python dart and they're taking it
out of dark they have big numbers are
arbitrary precision integers value
objects we want to be an extensible
system for adding all sorts of primitive
types there shouldn't just be these
hard-coded number bullying and string
primitives and no undefined in
JavaScript we want to allow other things
like symbol which is coming in es6 which
is a way of making an identifier for a
property in an object that cannot be
spelled by any string cannot collide
with any string it is like an intern
symbol and Lisp in 64 and you and 64 you
need them no js' people need them for
low-level io interfaces where you know
big memory machines have more than 32
bits of dress space I have a prototype
patch it's a little bit rough that I
need to dust it off for SpiderMonkey
implementing these and I'm going to
carry that through and I think these are
important to get into the standard
there's also sim d-types the sort of
short vectors that you see in in the
various vector units in CPUs or in
chipsets these days in 32 times four and
thirty times eight
coming we're gonna start with four and
float32 times 4 we'll get to eight
float32 itself is interesting it's very
important for graphics and WebGL and GPU
it turns out you can use float32 arrays
typed arrays today and depending on the
operations because certain operations
preserve equivalence between 32-bit and
64-bit floating-point in I Triple E you
can project values back into 64 bits and
not have anything go wrong jets can make
some optimizations already but we would
like to have flow 32 in the language as
a bonafide type and that's another use
case for value objects then there's big
now I mentioned arbitrary precision
integers
there's decimal which IBM loves they
almost want decimal it's actually an I
Triple E standard 754 are rational you
should talk to schemers and they say oh
I don't have a lot of use for rational
it's kind of attractive for some things
but it's rarely used complex numbers are
important for scientific computing so
when you talk about value objects you
have to think about operators because it
would be terribly painful and I'll show
why a little bit not have operators and
the operators that can be overloaded in
the proposal I'm working on are those
lovely bitwise operators thank goodness
they're there for asthma Jess I added
those because they were in C and Java
really cuz they're and C double equals
has to be overloaded bullets not an
equivalence relation it does some funky
stuff you want to make it do the right
thing for certain certain types if you
have a bunch of number types you want
their zeros probably be double equal I
would say less than and less than or
equal to the shift operator is including
triple right shift the unsigned right
shift in Java
rest of its from C the unary operators
are down at the bottom the plus and
minus the binary captives and the
multiplication division operators
boolean test and complement these are
actually important than add some Jas and
I'll talk about why we're not allowing
other operators to be overloaded not
equals and bang kind of important for
certain identities we don't want any
value object to be able to produce
nonsense contradictions
then there's the DeMorgan laws
point though I'm getting too nerdcore
tell me about I figure you want you want
the hardcore stuff right and just simple
stuff like this you want not equals to
be the same as not it double equals
so can't overload those they're also
obviously problems with relational is if
you allow all the combinations so only
greater than and greater than or equal
to and you handle the West then sorry
only less than less or equal to you
handle the other ones by transposing the
terms that's easy but why do we need
less than or equal to as well as less
than well it turns out nan is neither
greater than nor less than itself
it's unordered again I get blamed for
this it's I Triple E 754 it's an ancient
standard that made its way into hardware
in the seventies I think and we're stuck
with it so and by the way nan stands for
not a number if you say type of number
nan you get number so go figure strict
equality operators are the ones the
Crocker tells you you should only ever
use I personally don't subscribe to that
I could talk about why a little bit and
those do need to be preserved strictly
so what they're doing with value objects
is just looking at sort of looking at
the bits at least four simple integer
types when you get again with
floating-point types you have to worry
about nan and then it's irreflexive it's
not equal to itself that's really crazy
and you can optimize these strict
operators but they are not overloaded
they are kind of primitive those are you
know Python might wonder how to
implement this why not use methods when
you have binary operators a plus B you
can sometimes implement them with a pair
of methods and you chain a certain way
it has some drawbacks one of them is if
you're adding a value object and a
number if the value objects on the left
then you call the add method but if it's
on the right you have to call the
reverse add method or something
equivalent and however you do it it ends
up making more code and it gets ugly it
also requires all your methods in this
double dispatch system for the binary
operators to know about all the possible
type combinations which is just not
modular you end up writing case analysis
inside the methods as you go and you
cannot extend somebody else's method you
have to wrap and delegate you have to
do your own compositional rapping which
is kind of pain say you have complex and
rational types and you want to make a
complex number whose real and imaginary
parts instead of being doubles or
irrational you should make a rat Plex
but you can't if you use double dispatch
without wrapping extra allocations so
the slide you can long time ago from
somebody used to work on v8 I think he
stole Google never met him smart guy
interacted with him ah yes discussed
which is very productive though
sometimes noisy lists we run for
JavaScript standards work and he
basically was reviving I'm not sure if
he intended it a whole theory of
operators called or generalized
functions called multi methods that can
be dispatched on the types of all their
arguments this goes back to Common Lisp
and got cleaned up and Dylan and
language called Cecil by Craig chambers
which inspired me here so one of the
ideas with multi methods is you don't
have to have this double dispatch where
each method knows about the type of its
other argument or can't handle it
instead you kind of have a negotiation
where the two operands handshake and
find the right method and this is a
little bit hairy to nerdcore but the
idea is that you look in the left
operand V and the right operand you and
you see if they each have the right part
of the handshake one will be the symbol
name double added by the way when you
see the double add that's used in the
yes expect that means it's a internal
symbol may not be available to the
implementation and when you're looking
at you you look for double add underbar
RI just call it that it has to be a
different symbol has to be for the
right-hand operand and if you find sets
of functions you then intersect them if
you find one function you've got your
answer that's the function you call with
two arguments if you find zero there's
no such method multi method and if you
find more than one you have an ambiguous
call so this ends up letting you write
very clean implementations of the
combinations instead of doing the case
analysis inside the methods you can
write a function for each combination
that's short it's inlinable it's fast
and you can sort of overload them you
can add them and this is the
functional API that Christian pleasure
Hansen proposed at the time now I don't
think we want an API so I'm going to
talk about syntax people must have
syntax it's just an obvious user
interface affordance
so after c-sharp I've already got in my
prototype spider monkey patch is zero
capital L for you know zero 64-bit value
and one L and so on ul for unsilent 64
bits unsigned long full of 32 OB F big
num f-sharp used capital I but some
people object to that something like
that complex numbers imaginary parts so
n m for money is what you used for
decimal apparently this is sort of
standard and we need a syntax mechanism
for these things these these literals
are evaluated like a regular expression
literal is then you have to have some
kind of way of plugging into the syntax
and generating a implicit function call
to construct these things so that means
something like this and this I'm gonna
put before tc39 next week at this time
this looks fairly attractive it's based
on the class syntax in es6 there's a
value P textual keyword in front of
class to tell you this is a value class
declaration not a class declaration by
default the name of the class would also
give you the type of type we think both
for convenience people really want type
of 0 lb in 64 they don't want it to be
like object or number and in fact type
of has this this interesting
relationship with double equal and
triple equal if you know two things are
the same type of type and they're double
equal then you know they're triple equal
and also if you know two things are
triple equal then you know they're type
of types are the same and they're double
the code implies both ways that is not
just a coincidence that's something we
made sure of in the early days yes one
and it's something to keep this going
off the rails in subtle ways so we're
trying to preserve that that's another
reason to have a type of be different
for these new value objects and you can
see a constructor here what would be
different about the value class versus
the es6 classes that you would get an
implicit freeze of the return value
might be a deep freeze depends on how
other things work out in
the implementation and then I have this
new syntax for inspired by crate
chambers Cecil language for the various
multi method combinations point 2d plus
number and number holes point 2d point
2d plus point 2d again you get the short
inlinable fairly simple methods you
don't have to do switches or if else
trees to analyze the case combinations
of the other operand so this is looking
attractive and I'm going to carry it
forward next topic up in these low-level
affordances is kind of related to value
objects and this is something some of
you know about called sim D stands for
single instruction multiple data in your
modern multi-core super CPUs and your
system-on-a-chip phone CPUs you have
these little short vector units that are
pretty close to the CPU has to get to
and then they can do instead of for ads
and in a row they can do the ads in
parallel and they produce a vector and
they consume vectors these vectors are
fixed length it's kind of cool too
because there's actually been progress
here we know what these are wanted by
low-level hackers game hackers DSP
hackers it turns out John mcCutchan
spoke earlier has added them to dart VM
and that's not a problem because dart2js
needs them in j s so j s has to keep up
with dart and the incentives on
everyone's side to make that happen so
we're actually working on this together
it's a joint production of Google and
tell Mozilla right now with tc39
following along and keeping consensus
and we expect this could pop out in
engines pretty soon john already has a
poly fillable sim D API on github you
can use it it uses typed arrays for
storage it does not of course paralyze
into those vector units I mentioned
those hardware units but the jets could
do this pretty quickly and it's going to
be pretty sweet when it gets optimized
and it's it's fairly functional API
which means it'll line up with that
multi-method function based double
dispatch system I showed earlier and I
think you want that operator syntax you
might say well why not just use sim do
not add why not just call functions you
know will live there's some experience
to the contrary this is from Cameron
Purdy's blog awhile ago it's still good
funny read first he mocks son for
leaving out
real syntactic affordances for big
integer and big decimal and then the
first comment from Bob McWhorter talks
about some Wall Street code review where
they were looking at Java code and
people were using big decimal but they
kind of got tired of not having
operators so they extracted the double
values which are imprecise binary
floating-point representations of the
big decimals and then they just used
plus and there went the profit margin or
the national debt down the drain so you
know without operators without literals
people just don't use this stuff they
fall back on the convenience stuff and
it's just a hazard another low level
affordance I'm going to talk about
quickly is threads I think I said
threads suck once and I had a blog post
you can read about that but when you're
compiling these c or c++ game engines
they don't care right grandma don't care
it's it's data racist you know we're
fine we use new taxes or whatever the
trick is to keep this racy shared memory
buffer that might be only for the c or
c++ that's been compiled to JavaScript
from leaking out into the rest of the
JavaScript language or javascript vm's
like v8 and all the rest room they're
they're not multi-threaded they don't
want to take blocks on objects we think
we have a way to do this but I have
little to say about that I'm just going
to plow right ahead to an update on
Azzam J s as I'm Jas you know people are
kind of skeptical they think oh it's
only this Firefox thing it's not true
on the other hand speed on the web
consists of many things Network layer
it's a big one
Daum graphics and JavaScript but this is
Jay s con so I'm gonna talk about Jay s
speed I don't care about the other stuff
how fast is yes one measure that we're
using is for something big code base
like the epic Unreal Engine based
Citadel demo which is on Lion it's a
million lines c++ opengl to WebGL all
standardized Web Audio based they had an
open al layer doesn't just run in
Firefox well it runs in Chrome well now
and it should run in Safari and ie
they're working in Safari on LVM based
high performance optimizations and the
the chakra leads were on Microsoft's
channel I and the other months saying
that they are bullish on Asmodeus so
stuffs happening we're already within
spitting distance of native code speed
you can see some of the macro benchmarks
below the - like box 2d we're actually
1.2 times slower than native less than 2
times slower less than one-and-a-half
times slower and we're gonna keep
closing those gaps we're using this
stuff too because we have to Firefox OS
doesn't have a native developer kit
we're using in scripting to get C and
C++ cross-compiled automatically so I'm
gonna show first of all where's my water
I hope the volume is gonna work yeah the
short demo this is Firefox OS on a nexus
4 refusing for development this is the
Disney hit game of the new ones out but
it's running well and it didn't require
any rewriting it is cross-compiled
there's still some tuning to do it's
kind of alpha stage we're not happy with
code loading but I think that's
improving even as I speak and my my
lovely demo assistant here manages to
not get a single rubber session they'll
cut a demo so you'll have to excuse that
if you play this game you didn't get the
dirt up top so now the Ducks room Wow
okay but at least he got his water you
can see the the fluid simulations
working this is all running high frame
rate WebGL uploading from the CPU this
is how we intend to port
high-performance games and other apps
that are written in C or C++ to Firefox
OS hub it should they should work across
the web there's no reason people to
regret coming there's huge catalogues of
games out there that can work this way
nobody should rewrite them we shouldn't
force anybody to write a bunch of HTML
Javascript canvas put pixel pushing it
should be done through the existing code
paths that have been GPU optimized three
years based on OpenGL and got one duck
Wow okay I'm gonna have to get a better
demo assistant so now I'm gonna take my
life in my own hands as I usually do and
show you a couple of real demos which
include this Kang access chart here's
the oh sorry yeah I lost it thanks now I
have to mirror huh forgive me I'll go
fast
oh yeah it's faster that way isn't it
okay so this is Unreal Engine 3
Unreal Tournament the the sanctuary
level and it's a little bit slow code
loading you're still working at it
that's that's going to require us to do
worker paralyzed code compilation which
we can do with function futures if you
can't imagine what those are but it's
pretty straightforward to do that and
once we do that I think we're in good
shape on gameplay we have gamepad
somebody spoke about that earlier we
have other input affordances that are
part of the web platform now they're
coming along and no it's not going well
I think it's my first demo fail at this
No
there it is all right skip the fly
through and go straight to the game I
have to allow it to be full screen and
now you see my mad skills
well it's laggy it's not so fast hmm I
think I lost my athletes they asked
optimizations when I still loaded the
latest Firefox nightly painful okay let
me try something else see if this is
truly something I can blame on the
nightly build this is I will try and
hold that before I try and cram I'll try
it in Firefox Aurora when it works it's
faster than chrome stole but they're
catching up and we actually have people
working on making making sure that you
don't need to use azzam to get the
optimizations now here I'm gonna play
banana bread and I'm gonna make sure I
don't have BOTS because they're just
gonna kill me I suck at this game but
what's cool about this game is WASD
drives me around and then if you look
over here that is dude running in a
worker
running at a worker rendering to a
canvas so it's a game within a game it's
not a conception and the weird thing is
I can then switch to that game if I hit
a vertical bar how about I'm gonna do a
new game now you tell me what's to
choose so you know this doesn't canned
second third what I'm gonna I'm gonna
die I'm gonna do will this hurt okay now
who remembers doom now I'm gonna have to
use the arrow keys in here and ctrl + to
shoot I think yeah and if I if I use
WASD I'm in the outer game not that it
doesn't any good it's gonna be some
awful like taco demon killing me
oh let's see can I make it a switch go
where's the bad guys they're around here
somewhere
Oh teleport nothing's happening that's
good cuz I want to live all right that
seems to work in it seems to be full
speed either ice also so I'm gonna go
back here and with your indulgence to do
this one more time it is a little hairy
running nightly build because sometimes
something in the Azzam type checker
doesn't like previously compiled in
script encode blob which is just a bunch
of JavaScript it's minified and this
long load time makes me think that might
be implicated all right maybe I should
try Chrome what do you think I could try
Firefox or aura that's play a better
idea let's try that so Row 2
this one okay at least you know I'm
doing the real deal here epic demos
sanctuary crap I think I have two things
running let's write anyway here we go
this is this is probably gonna verify
better let's see how fast it loads to be
faster
preparing javascript and down yeah this
is it this is the real deal I think
let's hope it's Aurora it's not nightly
so it can't change on me that fast
fly through full speed oh wow okay
where's my rockets yeah they are
keep those BOTS there down there I think
crap to have mad skills also I'm
invincible
I'm overtime I apologize and get back to
this all right so I talked at Jay's
coffee us about the two JavaScript's the
hand-coded lovely JavaScript most to you
right and the compiler produced Azzam or
similar that compilers produced I had a
metaphor John Henry and the steam hammer
and though you knew John Henry's are
heroic and mighty you might after
beating the steam number one see my
classroom broken heart and I didn't want
that to happen I was really worried
about it I felt responsible
again just turned that watchword and you
know there's a scene some of you may
know from Breaking Bad I think I can
show that if I'm allowed to it in digits
okay we got two java scripts to worry
about it bothers me and we have the hand
coded one and we have the compiler
generated one but it's not so bad
true that the yin and the yang the cool
Yin of hand coded JavaScript for the hot
yang of compiler generated JavaScript
which is making my laptop melt and and
yet I don't have to worry too much
because I think we're on an inevitable
evolutionary path toward JavaScript
being the universal runtime and I think
Java scripts going to prevail also as a
source language that you all love to use
I think there will be JavaScript
conferences in the future maybe in the
far future and if I'm right
even this lovely Pelican which in some
ways is a happy creature despite
evolution making it look like a urinal
you know javascript has some of that
characteristic to a 210 days in May but
always bet on Jas thank you
you
you